ok on en rêvait vous avez bien madame
sarah je vais très très bien joué à new
york
ouais enfin ça ça me fait un certain
plaisir parce que les cachets sont
magnifiques et en france lormand cet
épouvantable la vie augmente de jour en
jour mais publicitairement ils sont un
peu choquant ah bon oui c'est très
curieux les affiches qu'ils ont préparée
madame sarah bernardt la célèbre aîné
jean bis de france
non ce qui me m'attriste beaucoup cette
coutume on court j'ai des élèves adorent
mme surtout une une petite que j'adore
son père ne voulait pas qu'elle fasse de
théâtre est vraiment ce serait dommage
un très très très grand qu'à venir dans
la poésie et elle ira très très loin là
d'ailleurs
oui à les laver à nous l'entendrez par
pourquoi maintenant comme elles viennent
s'asseoir avec nous s'asseoir avec nous
nous avons rêvé comme un saint bernard 7
à 6
ces élèves sont debout non non elle ne
viendra pas elle est trop grande sa tête
des passerelles et rend manioc jeu tu
veux le dire un poème
non je vous dis elles ne reprendront
insisté madame chérie je pars fais moi
plaisir je l'avais pris dutil de jean
sarment est mignonne
je vous écris vous êtes eux loin
mon amour ne vous touche pour un même et
vous ennuyer peut-être j'ai mis la mer
entre nous deux
je vous écris d'un pan boum cette lettre
je sens vainqueur et sans espoir
je viens à vous par habitude à cause de
la solitude de ma chambre d'hôtel ce
soit et d'un vieux rêve qui persistent
grave et triste
vous ne me répondrez jamais et cela je
le sais d'ores et ce sera à terme
exigences
d'ailleurs
le ferai pas exprès vous ne me devez
rien je sais me
je vous écris pourquoi pourquoi je crois
que le meilleur de moi vous suit par les
rues de la ville lire et vous cette
lettre me pardonnez lui d'être inutile
je suis loin il a de l'avenir
et elle est bien roulée bien cette
petite marque